foreign
every Sunday night when I was a kid
my family would go to Celia's Mexican
restaurant
a family-owned chain in the Bay Area
I loved that place
we were a big group 10 people total
so they had to push three tables
together to make a big long table right
in the middle of the dining room
as soon as we sat down the chips and
salsa arrived the chips were warm
perfectly salted and thin
my favorite
when it came time to order I got the
same thing every time
two chicken enchiladas and a virgin
strawberry daiquiri
something about it was magical
today that meal from celias would cost
about 25 dollars
what do you think
is that worth it
what is a restaurant meal worth
I've spent much of my career thinking
about this question
about 15 years after my formative
experiences at places like celias
I quit my consulting job to go into the
restaurant industry full-time
I started on the finance team of a
Restaurant Group
and before I started one of my friends
said to me
once you see behind the curtain
restaurants will lose their magic
but I brushed It Off
my first day on the job I got there at
8am
in Consulting people would just be
pouring their first cups of coffee at 8
am
but when I got to the restaurant the
whole place was buzzing
several people on the team had been
there since 4 AM
people were accepting deliveries wiping
tables reviewing reservations folding
napkins chopping blending you name it
my first meeting with the chef happened
while he was breaking down a whole fish
the whole place was alive
and everyone who worked in it was doing
everything they could to make sure that
the people who walked through the door
that night would be happy
and they'd be on their feet for hours
many of them staying late Into the Night
and then they would do it again
the next day
and the next
and even though the restaurant was full
every night
the team was not paid enough
the work was hard and thankless
and there was no Prophet to speak of
I was indeed struggling to hold on to
the magic
a few months later
I went to dinner at a local Italian
restaurant with some friends
we had an amazing time we drank wine we
talked for hours and at the end of the
meal one of my friends said to me
well that was great but fifteen dollars
for pesto gnocchi I could have made that
at home for five
what
people in the group were nodding but I
was genuinely confused
make that at home
have you ever tried to make gnocchi from
scratch
and and what about pesto I mean a
perfectly seasoned pesto
is no easy feat
I literally still think about a pesto I
had in Italy 10 years ago
but my friend's comments upset me for a
deeper reason
she was missing the point
my friend was expressing what a lot of
people believe
restaurants are valuable primarily
because they sell food
but this is why so many restaurants are
struggling
delicious food is only one part of a
restaurant experience
and by equating the price we pay
simply with food
we underestimate the true value of
restaurants
so I'll ask again
what is a restaurant meal worth
the true value of a restaurant meal
is hospitality
and to really understand this
we all have to look behind the curtain
after years in the industry I can tell
you
seeing behind the curtain does not ruin
the magic
in fact understanding restaurants more
deeply
makes them so much more magical
and I am not saying that everything
behind the curtain is pretty
it is not
but at their core
restaurants are about people caring for
other people
in Latin hospice
means both guest and stranger
hospitality is turning a stranger into a
guest
and it's not necessarily Flawless
service
often it's the little things
a warm smile when you walk in the door
a water glass that's never empty for too
long
a clean plate for your next course
the magic of a restaurant
is how it makes you feel
and as I thought of this I was
transported back to Celia's
again sitting at that big long table
right in the middle of the dining room
but now I saw it with new eyes
that table didn't just fit 10 people
it made me feel important
they literally rearrange the dining room
for us
that virgin strawberry daiquiri
was not just delicious
it made me feel fancy
and those chips
were not just warm and perfectly salted
they were placed right in the middle of
the table
so everyone in my family had to lean in
to grab one
bringing us all a bit closer to one
another
and perhaps most importantly of all
this was not just a Sunday night dinner
it was respite from the world for a bit
sitting there eating and laughing with
people I loved
meant that I didn't have to think about
the looming day of middle school that
lay ahead
[Music]
my parents didn't have to think about
grocery shopping or dishes
my grandpa got a couple of hours of
uninterrupted time with his grandkids
what is a restaurant meal worth
respite from the world
connection to those we love
to me that's worth a whole lot
and restaurants have had a rough go of
it
covid threatened the very core of the
industry
and now
family-owned sit-down restaurants like
celias
are forced to compete with the
subsidized growth of ghost kitchens
delivery
and coming soon
robots
if we want these places to survive
we have to start seeing them differently
so next time you go to a restaurant
look around
think about how all of the little things
make you feel
notice
how the restaurant
and most importantly the people who work
in it
facilitate connection
how you're more connected
to what you're eating
to who you're with
and to the community around you
once you peek behind the curtain
you'll see that hospitality
makes you feel valued
and hopefully you'll return the favor
thank you
all right